the video was quite hard to watch just
because of the level of abuse that was
going on and the age of the victim
before journey rwf I was in the military
I was an intelligence analyst basically
looking at all kinds of imagery from
drone imagery to satellite imagery bomb
damage assessment that kind of thing
I'm a senior Internet content analyst so
we take reports from the public and
pretty much remove indecent images of
children off the internet the images
come to us from members of the public or
report them to us they can do that
anonymously if they wish when we get the
images we have to figure out is it
sexual abuse and is the child under 18
the Baka what we do is removing content
online generally what we've seen before
if we get something new we have to act
fast really because that could be a
potential victim being abused at that at
that time I'd only been here about three
months when I got a new image in and it
was thumbnails on an image board and
alongside that was a video link the
image was probably found by a young lad
who just sort of thought something just
isn't right in an image she was quite
young and it was quite sexually explicit
the girl in a video was was clearly
underage and I got other members of the
team to come and sort of confirm my
fears
you could see by the the video and her
interactions with with her laptop that
she was being coddled and grooved online
[Music]
you're not just looking at the abuse but
you're looking at everything inside that
image you're looking at the room that
the child in
[Music]
every case is different there's no
handbook for this and there was a number
of things in the room that tied us in to
her location you take all the
information compiler compiled it all up
and send it to the police and then just
hope for the best
within a couple of days I got a phone
call at my desk from the police to tell
me that they found the victim in it
she'd been safeguarded
[Applause]
I'm just I'm just here Saten an office
processing reports to save a child from
a lifetime of abuse it's just I mean
it's an amazing feeling that we can do
it that we have the power to it all it
needs is one report the young lad that
report to us probably doesn't even
realize some what he's done and how he's
helped that child I don't think he has
any idea the kid he's done
[Music]
you